maybe it's true  we are fine a thousand lives we didn't  expect  but what I learned was  the powerful men don't have to be cruel  I got one guaranteed life  I was gonna women  I had a plan  do you think that we got where we are by  letting some embrace muscle  that's what you think we are you're  making a fatal miscalculation with  clerks bankers police officers and we  even got a judge and if you don't have  to fight us  no rain bloody Hill fired now you all  you love so you're threatening me with  people who are more powerful than you  exactly so what am I talking to you for  we're all going to hell even if you win  today's battle there's so much violence  and what you do